hello i'm claire richardson welcome to
our special coverage on britain's queen
elizabeth ii who has died at the age of
96. she passed away surrounded by her
children and other family members at the
balmoral castle in scotland buckingham
palace has just made the announcement
now people are already beginning to
gather to pay their respects to
britain's longest reigning monarch
renowned for her sense of unfailing duty
tributes pouring in from around the
world for a woman who was not only the
british queen but also the head of the
commonwealth members of the royal family
had rushed to scotland to be by the side
of the queen after doctors took the
extremely unusual step of saying they
were concerned about the health of the
monarch and that she should remain under
medical supervision let's get straight
across to our correspondent carl nasman
who's going to join us outside of
buckingham palace we'll be going to him
in just a moment um first though we're
going to speak to dw's alex forrest
whiting who covers uk politics to get
more on this momentous development uh
alex tell us more about what we know so
far i mean really claire this is
momentous this uh queen elizabeth ii
um had been the reigning monarch for 70
years
this was her 70th anniversary year of
being queen she came to the throne in
1952
and now after
seven decades
she has passed away
in balmoral that is her residency in the
north of scotland and as you said
surrounded by her closest family members
who spent the day trying to get to her
bedside as quickly as possible just
within the last hour we know that some
of her own children um had arrived at
aberdeen airport and then made the
journey to balmoral
to see the queen and to be with her
prince charles her son uh was uh with
her at the time and also
his sister princess anne and other
members of the family as well but um i
cannot
begin to even describe what a huge
moment this is not just for people
across the united kingdom but people
across the world i'm given that she was
the head of state of 14 other countries
apart from the uk so this is an
extraordinary announcement that has been
made and we are just looking at footage
of buckingham palace that flag flying at
half mast alex she was not uh in london
but you mentioned at the scottish
residence um why was she there
she was supposed to be back at
buckingham palace she spends her uh
spent her summer uh at balmoral but she
was clearly unwell to be able to make
the journey back to london and this was
an enormous week in british politics uh
the politics said goodbye to boris
johnson who was prime minister and
welcomed in uh liz truss who is the new
british prime minister
it should have this
handover should have happened at
buckingham palace in london but instead
they both had to travel
to balmoral to meet the queen there and
that was became very clear
that she was not well and could not make
the journey back to buckingham palace we
knew that she had mobility problems in
the run-up to this but then only today
did doctors
or did bucky and palace make it clear
that doctors
were very concerned about her health
and so concerned that her family members
had to make the trip up to balmoral to
be with her by her bedside indeed that
lunchtime announcement um they said the
queen was comfortable uh highly unusual
for them to make this sort of
announcement absolutely we've already
heard people sending her well wishes
those people who were able to travel to
balmoral to be by her side the royal
family can you tell us a little bit more
about who was there yes so we know that
prince charles who
should now be king
charles was at
balmoral already along with his sister
princess anne and before she died we
understand that her other children
prince andrew and prince edward also
arrived in time as did prince william
her grandson um and uh we
also understood that his brother prince
harry was on his to balmoral i cannot
tell you if he got there in time or not
because the as as you said the
announcement has just been made but she
was certainly surrounded by those very
closest to her
thank you alex so much for that um queen
elizabeth performed her last official
duties on tuesday
when she appointed liz truss as the new
uk prime minister after accepting the
resignation of outgoing prime minister
boris johnson
we know that although she'd increasingly
withdrawn from high-profile royal duties
in recent years
she did spend her seven decade reign
dedicated to the role of the queen
we're looking there at pictures from
buckingham palace as crowds gather
uh
no british monarch reigned for as long
as queen elizabeth ii
she was a constant in a time of dramatic
change
all was disciplined
all was dutiful
a life of public service
right until the end
in 1926 elizabeth came into the world
she was not born to be queen
but when her uncle king edward viii
abdicated after less than a year on the
throne elizabeth's father was crowned
king
and his daughter suddenly became the
crown princess
she accepted the task and took it
seriously even in her youth i declare
before you all
that my whole life
whether it be long or short
shall be devoted to your service
and to the service of our great imperial
family to which we all belong
during world war ii elizabeth did her
military service as a mechanic
after the war she married naval officer
philip mountbatten her great love
[Music]
one year later prince charles was born
the first of four children
[Music]
in february 1952 her father king george
vi died
elizabeth replaced him while on a trip
to africa
the tragic news reached princess
elizabeth and her husband while in kenya
and the new queen left immediately for
london
elizabeth ii was only 25 years of age
her coronation ceremony did not take
place until the following year in june
1953
the ceremony itself was one of the first
world events to be broadcast on
television
an estimated 300 million people watched
around the globe
[Music]
the queen took the throne at a time when
the british empire was losing its
importance
many former colonies gained their
independence while at the same time a
new global conflict began
with the cold war
as queen elizabeth was not allowed to
pursue her own political agenda
but she was the most important
representative of her country and head
of the commonwealth
in that role she tirelessly traveled the
world in the decades that followed
[Music]
at home elizabeth was intent on boosting
the royal family's popularity also with
the help of the media
the spectacular wedding of her son
charles to diana spencer in the summer
of 1981 was the most watched tv
broadcast of all time
but when what appeared to be a perfect
royal family life began to unravel
the tabloid press was merciless
in the 1990s the newspapers feasted on
the royal affairs and divorces
charles and diana's marriage failed
and in 1997 diana died in a traffic
accident
the worldwide outpouring of sympathy was
overwhelming but the royal family
struggled to find sympathetic words
she was an exceptional and gifted human
being
in good times and bad
she never lost her capacity to smile and
laugh
nor to inspire others with her warmth
and kindness
this was when the royals popularity hit
an all-time low
diana's sons princes william and harry
did not talk about the trauma of their
mother's death until years later
when harry's marriage to u.s television
star megan markel was repeatedly
exploited by the tabloids the couple
made a radical exit
they officially turned their backs on
the royal family ultimately moving to
the united states
there they complained in interviews
about racism in the media and also in
the palace
compared to the other members of the
royal family the queen led a quiet
marriage
she was married to her childhood
sweetheart prince philip for 73 years
he was an important pillar of support
for her
which made the moment of parting all the
more difficult
in the spring of 2021 philip died aged
99.
[Music]
owing to the coronavirus pandemic the
funeral took place with a very small
circle of mourners
elizabeth was alone
it was an image that touched many
but only a few days later she was again
representing the country receiving
ambassadors via video conference and
participating in zoom meetings with
scientists and this wonderful work
you're all doing
so
it's great pleasure to see you all yeah
thank you so much
thank you your majesty bye
in a world that has changed radically
elizabeth was a constant mainstay
[Music]
committed to tradition
but not closed to the new
and most of the critics of the british
royal family paid tribute to the queen
for her long life in service to her
country
and to the commonwealth
[Music]
you you're watching a special edition of
dw news britain's queen elizabeth ii has
died she was 96 years old
she was the longest reigning monarch and
head of state in the world her death
means her son charles succeeds her
immediately he's expected to be
officially proclaimed king tomorrow and
embark on a tour of the united kingdom
over the coming days
britain's will observe a period of
mourning ahead of the royal funeral
the queen has been gradually stepping
back from public duties in recent years
due to failing health but she performed
her last official duties on tuesday when
she appointed liz truss as the new prime
minister
just looking at pictures here from
outside of buckingham palace as crowds
gather
i'd like to come back into the studio uh
for more analysis my colleague alex
forrest whiting joins me now um
alex this is an event of monumental
proportions can you tell us a little bit
about what this will mean not just for
the united kingdom but for the world
well the queen was obviously the queen
of great britain and northern ireland
but she was also the head of state of 14
other states and countries
including for example australia
and canada and others as well
she played a huge role across the globe
you have to remember that when she came
to reign 70 years ago
britain had an empire and many of those
countries obviously no longer ruled by
britain but are still part of
the commonwealth so very important uh to
the uk and the commonwealth was presided
over by uh queen elizabeth so she played
a very very important global role very
close to many people's hearts alex i
just want to jump in there we're just
seeing a foot man come out of buckingham
palace and post a notice
on the gates there that makes it
official um the official public notice
that queen elizabeth has passed away
um and we just look at the crowds there
it's extraordinary the number of people
who um are now gathering at buckingham
palace um it really i cannot stress just
what a
huge moment this is um for not just uh
the united kingdom but um
countries across the world she had been
on her throne for 70 years seven decades
um during a time in which the world has
significantly changed and i think had
really been such a bedrock for
particularly britain and it will be
difficult to imagine how life will
continue without her and i imagine that
um thousands tens of thousands of people
will now be gathering outside buckingham
palace and across london um as well
of course to as close to balmoral castle
up in the north of scotland as they can
get um the queen
of course many would have expected her
to be in london for this moment that's
how um operations had been planned for
when she was to pass away but she is in
scotland um
or was it in scotland at balmoral which
does mean that um everything that had
been planned will change quite
significantly and we knew she was unwell
that announcement made midday today that
um the buckingham palace and the doctors
were concerned about her they called the
family to rush up to balmoral um she
should have been here at buckingham
palace but because of those mobility
issues you've mentioned
she was up at her home in scotland we
now know that charles the prince of
wales is the new king um 73 years old
he's the longest waiting heir apparent
he's also going to be the oldest monarch
to take the british throne um can you
tell us a little bit more about the man
who will be replacing queen elizabeth ii
well obviously as you say he has been
waiting almost a lifetime for this role
i think it has been at times very
difficult for him
but he has um played i think it's fair
to say in the past few years a very good
second fiddle
to his mother the queen he has had to
take over various
roles for her for example
the state opening of parliament this
year in the house of lords which is a um
a big ceremonial role that the queen
would always do she couldn't do it this
year prince
now king charles
had to do that also he was at other
events that she would normally have been
at for example the remembrance day
services where she would always go and
she couldn't go to those either so i
think that this um comes as a very um
i mean prince uh prince charles i keep
calling him prince charles king charles
will have been waiting for this for some
time but you know he's still
um the queen's son and i imagine there
are many emotions that are going through
his mind at the moment um having to say
farewell to his mother and knowing now
that he has to try to carry her mantle
she was a woman who was so loved across
the world uh particularly
in the past few years and he now has to
step into that role and try to fill up
some very big shoes alex we've just seen
those live pictures of that notice
announcing the death of queen elizabeth
posted on the gates of buckingham palace
we do want to find out more about the
new king charles
we know that he's been taking over many
of the queen's duties traveling abroad
in her place let's see if we can take a
look now at the man who has waited so
long to be king
[Music]
he was dumped the perpetual prince
waiting to be king longer than any other
heir to the throne before him
charles philip arthur george mountbatten
windsor was born in 1948
the first son of princess elizabeth
he was four years old at his mother's
coronation
queen elizabeth ii passes from the abbey
consecrated and dedicated to her life
work
[Music]
after attending boarding school and
graduating from cambridge university
charles continued royal tradition by
serving in the royal air force and royal
navy
at 32 the world's most eligible bachelor
announced his engagement to lady diana
spencer 13 years as junior
just delighted and happy and i i'm
amazed that she's
been brave enough to take me on
the couple married in july 1981.
it was the wedding of the century and
captured the world's imagination
thousands came out to cheer and around
the globe hundreds of millions watched
the ceremony on their tv screens
[Applause]
there we go the couple had two sons
william and harry
but the fairy tale wasn't to last
charles and his wife seemed increasingly
unhappy
the press published leaked phone
conversations that showed charles was
having an affair with a former
girlfriend camilla parker-bowles
in 1992 they made their split official
it is announced from buckingham palace
that with regret the prince and princess
of wales have decided to separate
a year after the couple divorced diana
was killed in a car crash in paris after
being hounded by paparazzi
charles accompanied her body back to
britain
there was an outpouring of public grief
at diana's death
and with this scandal surrounding their
marriage not yet forgotten
public opinion of prince charles and the
royal family had never been so low
[Music]
charles continued to dedicate himself to
his royal duties and his charitable
causes
most notably the prince's trust a
charity he set up to help improve the
lives of disadvantaged young people
[Applause]
his relationship with camilla
parker-bowles continued to develop
and in 2005 the couple were married in a
civil ceremony
together they have carried on charles
work on sustainability
he has always been passionate about the
environment promoting organic farming
and biodiversity on his estate but also
on a global stage
at the cop 26 climate summit in glasgow
he urged global leaders to do more to
limit global warming
the cost of inaction is far greater
than the cost of prevention time has
quite literally run out
as his mother stepped back from some of
her responsibilities in recent years
and especially after the death of his
father prince philip
charles took a more significant and
active part in discharging royal duties
from king and waiting to king and
training
now charles will take on the role that
he has been preparing for his entire
life
[Music]
you're watching dw news if you're just
joining us we do have some breaking news
the britons queen elizabeth ii has died
she was 96 years old
the longest reigning monarch and head of
state in the world her death now means
her son charles succeeds her immediately
he's expected to be officially
proclaimed king tomorrow and embark on a
tour of the united kingdom over the
coming days you're looking there at
footage of the notice saying that the
queen has died peacefully at balmoral
this afternoon that's of course her home
in scotland
now britons are going to be observing a
period of mourning ahead of the royal
funeral the queen had been gradually
stepping back from public duties in
recent years due to her failing health
but she did perform her last official
duties just this tuesday when she
appointed liz truss as the new uk prime
minister and saw that transfer of power
from former prime minister boris johnson
i want to see if we can get across to
our correspondent in london berget mass
hi thank you so much for joining us can
you tell us the latest from london on
the death of the queen
well it has just been
formally announced and of course this is
a
really momentous day i think for the
british nation because for many people
the queen has just always been there
she's been such a
she has a steadmar he's steadfast
royal and and really leading the country
especially recently through through
quite tough times when britain is really
in turmoil and seeing an energy crisis a
cost of living crisis and now during
this time to lose the monarch that's
really presented this stability over the
decades um i think that will that will
be very very tough for a lot of british
people and we don't know much more than
what buckingham palace has announced we
we know that she hasn't been in great
health but then again we've only two
days ago
seen her
say goodbye to prime minister boris
johnson when he flew up to bomba moral
for his last visit as a prime minister
and she she met liz trust the new prime
minister only two days ago and we've
seen pictures of of her smiling atlas
trust she was um having a walking stick
but but she was you know really
welcoming uh the new prime minister and
carrying out her duties really
up to the end so that is quite
remarkable
we're just seeing some vehicles uh
coming out of the gates however on that
notice we just saw posted to the gates
of buckingham palace the information
that the king and queen consort will be
returning to london tomorrow after
spending the night at balmoral
the home in scotland
um
berget
is it fair to say that the atmosphere in
britain is going to be one of mourning
now
it is definitely wonderful morning it's
it's going to be there we expecting that
there will be
some sort of holiday a day of mourning
and
parliament for the moment cannot pass
any new law so it's it's going to be
something that is
momentous for the country and not just
for the uk i mean obviously across the
world the queen is being admired she's
head of state um of other countries so
it's it's it's something that ripples
not just true through the uk but also i
think throughout the world and there's
been so much attention
uh
directed at the british royal family um
their whatever have it happens to them
is being followed across the world so
so yes for for the uk but also around
the world this is going to be to be a
very very sad and reflective moment i
think for a lot of people
how much of a sense is there that this
is the end of an era
there is there is definitely the censor
at the end of an era i mean the queen
she's uh she's done 21 i think over 21
our
visits over over the decades she's been
she's been the patron of over 500
charities or organizations so she's been
really she's been out and about and
she's met so many people i personally
know so many people who have somehow met
the queen in some capacity um shaken her
hand and so she she is such a
she's been just always there when um
when it was the the diamond jubilee i
spoke to uh a few ladies that were
just preparing for a party in her honor
and and what they admired in her was
that she has such a strong work ethic
that she
she's almost never taken any time off
even
most recently when her health was not
fantastic anymore and she had coveted uh
earlier in the year that she's been
she's been carrying out her duties um
via zoom so she's really she's always
been there and there's been this this
sense i think in the country that she's
been um she's just always been around
and she's been this role model of of um
just carrying on and and doing what
needs to get done and this is i think
what uh what people uh will be missing
and burger it's certainly been a long
and difficult day uh can you tell us a
little bit about how the media and
british institutions have been preparing
for this i mean a lot of the protocol
was meant to be secret
yes but it has um
it has been it has been reported so this
is going to be an intense um 10 days
when the queen's um
we we don't we don't know it um for sure
but we're expecting that uh the queen um
will be because she has died in scotland
she will be
laid to rest in edinburgh and people
will be expected for the next days to
come there and pay their respects and
then it's expected that the body will be
will be carried to london where she will
later rest so the funeral is expected to
be in 10 days and
how exactly that will unfold with a
travel from scotland to to london i
think we will know more about that soon
all right berget mass reporting for us
from london thank you so much for that